hello and welcome to this video playing
michelle here from finland finland that
is because I'm poof okay so playing this
line in the in the English opening with
them this quick be4 idea yeah against
632 against t6d one if i remember
correctly yes so black place with just
six year i think i have to do this now i
tried a couple of times to played with
III but this doesn't really gap doesn't
really work all that well there is 95
happening and UNITA three is better be
sick so I can't do thumped on something
on the long diagonal of it it probably
doesn't doesn't do all that much so here
the addy three blunder stuff I think III
queen bee three this kind of thing one
idea why this vapor should be 292 trade
the bishops white has a little bit more
space I mean black should be a very okay
here that is absolutely clear but it's
not a bad position for white it's
definitely interesting to play and I
wonder if he goes 'if I've here I know
it looks like yeah k doesn't do it
it was interesting though try to keep
more on the board and okay so d for now
it looks like the most natural move
let's do it expect them to take that's
an interesting way to do it oh but how
does he keep this poem now f5 while f5
looks wrong to goddess isn't that wrong
so I want you bring the night 36
if I go f3 is good III that that's not
good so how to do this the b5 move was
kind of annoying you can't start with
this having a look at be five as well
you can still play be five I but now how
to hard to believe f5 shocked me because
of that week is six square the night
only six is an extremely extremely
annoying piece you can even think about
this is this an interesting question
actually I could think about was also
interesting I can also think about not a
b5 in Knight to c6 this is also pretty
awful for black I wonder if this is
maybe even stronger to be honest because
that that kills all possible come to
play with with black playing b5 and he
has a hard time to take the knight on c6
giving me a pawn is wrong g5 know
that sorry that I can absolutely not
believe so both most make sense rook
takes also make sense even though it's
the sacrifice ok I take with the pond so
nitey six or bishop h3 is also strong
let's go Bishop h3
I just want to take it then 96 and f-5e
for hangs so k-96 just open up
everything here need the G file opened
quickly maybe g3 nope already goes into
desperation mode probably probably
correctly so I can even take on f7 here
for for for Rukia ok
check and it's interesting actually
which I mean I can take it home d to
what is that something stronger here
quindi for three
I don't don't really like that idea to
step into that pin so I try to bring the
Queen over here tweenage three-time
morning okay so go into age 6 this is
idea check
who actually did not I was somewhat
thinking my rookies on the C file that's
a good hallucination I do window here
right if he takes that check
Quinn g8 start working somehow no
maybe other kids otherwise it's it's a
win I think Kingda seven will win for me
kingi seven wins King out seven wins so
he has to do that sense and here I have
roped g1 I can take with the rook wow
that's super important on g one g one
check and d1 Queen check I can take with
the rook though and Bishop g8 I have
Queen deform or queen G 70mm check black
resign ok wow yeah it's still got a
little bit scary yeah interesting i'm
not sure about this here be five is it's
not bad but you can of course argue that
you should play on the Kings side where
the weaknesses are ya know ok 96 also
was good g5 hangs right but ok so I just
open up the position and went in I'm
surprised that the engine is still
thinking that this is viable for black
ads very hard to believe ok now it its
evaluation goes up somewhat ok I III
years possible didn't have this on the
right up maybe like III here and then
sacrifice or no Luke see aid may okay
this is difficult to cover so probably
h3 was wrong the engine just wants to do
this
maybe using this gravity kind of went
into panic mode and I don't think it
does work yeah check yeah look see one
wins but it looks scary it really looks
a bit scary yeah it was super important
that I had that I have work takes rook
takes you wanna hear that also should
win I'm on the seventh this point is is
covering the escape square so this is
these are check these rules you know
yeah here it's already over it's already
already oh man I probably could have
punished this a little bit better
actually what what he played okay anyway
thanks for watching